FIFTEENTH RULES COMMITTEE
MEETING. TO ORDER AND MADAM
SECRETARY WE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS BATES.
BATES HERE MINING ROTH ROTH HERE
WILK ATKINS HERE ATKINS HERE AND
FOUR OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO ARE HERE SENATOR --
MINING IS ON HIS WAY.
BOB SENATOR WILK IS ABSENT TODAY --
I THINK WE'RE GONNA HOLD ON
DOING A CONSENT CALENDAR UNTIL
MISTER MINING IS HERE IT MIGHT
BE EASIER THAT WAY AND IT'S NOT
A BIG DEAL SO.
BECAUSE WE HAVE APPOINTEES --
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEE READY. TO
PRESENT SO I'M GONNA GO AHEAD
AND INVITE.
THIS MINOR AND I AM HOPING IT'S
SURE REESE.
OKAY UP THESE ARE COMMISSIONERS
ON THE BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS.
AND THEY'RE GONNA COME UP
TOGETHER.
AND I WILL -- ASK MISS MINOR FOR
YOU TO START AND THEN -- WILL
TURN IT OVER TO YOU MR SHARIF
FEEL FREE TO INTRODUCE ANYONE
THIS WITH YOU THAT YOU WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE BECAUSE THIS IS
THEIR MOMENT TO SHINE -- AND
THEN GO RIGHT INTO YOUR OPENING
STATEMENT IF YOU HAVE ONE AND
THEN -- WE WILL LET EACH OF YOU
DO THAT -- AND THEN WE WILL GO
TO SENATORS AS IT RELATES TO
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS.
AND I'D LET THE RECORD REFLECT
THAT MR MONEY HAS JOINED US AND
WE WILL DO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
AFTER THIS.
WELCOME.
I HAVE A PROBLEM WHEN YOU'RE
HERE -- WITH THIS WITH ME TODAY
AND I ALSO HAVE MY DEAR FRIEND
ELIZABETH SECONDS WHO'S HERE
WITH US TODAY.
AND ALSO -- CHIEF OUR EXECUTIVE
OFFICER JENNIFER SHAPERS ALSO --
JOINED US TODAY WITH THE ONE
THING.
CHIEF COUNSEL COME TO FOR NEIL
IS ALSO AND JOINING.
US TODAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
ACTIONS AND SENATORS FOR THE
PAST THIRTY FOUR YEARS I HAVE
PROUDLY SERVED AS A PUBLIC
SERVICE STARTING MY CAREER IN
JUVENILE HALL.
BEFORE MOVING TO THE STATE
SYSTEM WITH THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH
AUTHORITY NOW THE DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE.
AFTER TWENTY YEARS OF WORKING
WITH YOU I TRANSFERRED TO ADULT
CORRECTIONS I'VE BEEN A
COMMISSIONER ON THE BOARD OF
PAROLE HEARINGS SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN I'D LIKE
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION TODAY AND I
WELCOME ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR SHARIF
THANK YOU MY PARENTS ARE HERE
TODAY MY FAMILY ARE IN HERE BUT
MY PARENTS ARE HERE IN SPIRIT.
SO GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR.
AND GOTTEN SENATORS.
MY NAME IS XL SURE RESULT THANK
YOU FOR CONSIDERING MY
CONFIRMATION.
OF APPOINTMENTS COMMISSIONER FOR
BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE EFFECT
OF OFFICER MISS JENNIFER
SCHAEFFER.
THE CHIEF COUNSEL MISSION FOR
NAIL.
CHIEF DEPUTY COMMISSIONER MISS
RANDA SKIP A DONOR.
THE ASSOCIATE CHIEF ALI THEIR
NAM ALONG WITH THE ALL THE
ADDITIONAL SOCIAL CHEESE.
LASTLY THE BACKBONE OF THE BOARD
OF PAROLE HEARINGS THE SUPPORT
STAFF.
IN THE AMAZING ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW JUDGES DEPUTY COMMISSIONERS
THAT I WORK ALONGSIDE.
I BRING TO THIS POSITION HAVE
NEARLY TWENTY YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE IN THE PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SECTOR.
BEFORE OF THE POINT IS
COMMISSIONER HAD THE HNOR TO
SERVE AS A MINISTER OF LAW JUDGE
TO BE COMMISSIONER. FOR THE
BORDER PAROLE HEARINGS WERE AND
I WORKED ALONGSIDE HIM THE MOST
DEDICATED KNOWLEDGEABLE LEGAL
MIND TO CALIFORNIA.
PRIOR TO THAT I WAS IN PRIVATE
PRACTICE HILL NUMEROUS HEARING
OFFICERS POSITIONS.
MY BACKGROUND EXPERTISE HAVE
GIVEN ME A GREAT DEAL OF
KNOWLEDGE AND EXPERTISE
EXPERTISE IN THIS AREAAS WELL.
AND A PLACE GREAT VALUE IN
PUBLIC SAFETY TEAM WORKS AND
EMPATHY.
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERATION
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH COMMA.
WE WILL MOVE INTO COMMENTS OF OF
THE RULES COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF
MR ROTH SENATOR ROTH I'M GONNA
START WITH YOU IF THAT'S OKAY
THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU MENTIONED.
CONGRATULATIONS TO BOTH OF YOU.
YEAH WE HAVE A VARIETY OF EXCUSE
ME REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS
AVAILABLE TO FOLKS IN OUR IN OUR
PRISON SYSTEM AND WE'RE VERY
INTERESTED IS.
AS ELECTED SIN WAS REBUILT
TATIAN PROGRAMS IN THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THEM -- IN YOUR
CAPACITY IS WHAT TO WHICH OF THE
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS DO YOU
FIND.
HAVE YOU FOUND TO BE MOST
EFFECTIVE.
OUR BEGIN BY STATING THE VICTIMS
AWARENESS PROGRAMS.
BECAUSE A LOT OF TIMES TO BE IN
MAKES AREN'T REALLY.
AWARE OF THEIR VICTIMS AND I
DON'T CARE ABOUT THEIR VICTIMS
INTO LATER ON IN THEIR
CORPORATION.
AND MANY OTHER BIG AND AWARENESS
PROGRAMS ACTUALLY HAVE.
AN OPPORTUNITY WHERE IT BY THE
INMATES ARE CONFRONTED WITH
OTHER VICTIMS OF FAMILY VICTIMS.
AND WHEN THEY SEE THE EMPATHY
THAT.
THE VICTIMS OF THE NEXT OF CAN
HAVE.
FOR THE INMATES THEY REALIZE
NUMBER ONE THERE HARM AND ALSO
FORGIVENESS AND THAT'S ONE OF
THE THINGS IS THIS PART OF
REHABILITATION.
IS HAVE AN INMATE'S.
FORGIVING THEMSELVES FOR THE
CRIMES AND THAT WAY THEY CAN
BEGIN THE PROCESS OF
REHABILITATION.
I THINK A LOT OF MANY OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT -- ARE COGNITIVE
BEHAVIORAL PROGRAMS THAT REALLY
FOCUS ON BEHAVIOR CHANGE AND
REALLY CHANGING THEIR THINKING.
IT HAVE HAVE BEEN REALLY
IMPORTANT -- AND AND VERY
EFFECTIVE IN ACTUALLY -- MAKING
SURE THAT OFFENDERS ARE ACTUALLY
CHANGING SO -- THERE ARE
PROGRAMS NOW THAT THERE REALLY
FOCUSING ON CHANGING THINKING
PATTERNS -- CHANGING THE WAY.
ONE OF THE PROGRAMS NOW THAT
SOME BASED ON COGNITIVE
BEHAVIORAL -- THERAPIES IS --
BUT THE LONG TERM OFFENDER
PROGRAM AND MANY OF THOSE
PROGRAMS THEY HAVE A CRIMINAL
THINKING WHICH REALLY GETS TO
THE THINKING PATTERNS THAT THEY
HAD AT THE TIME OF THE CRIME.
AND ALLOWS THEM TO REALLY
REFLECT BACK ON THAT AND THEN
REALLY START TO WORK ON CHANGING
THAT BANKING WHICH THEN.
WILL CHANGE THEIR BEHAVIOR SO I
THINK A LOT OF THE PROGRAMS THAT
FOCUS ON BEHAVIOR CHANGE -- ARE
QUITE EFFECTIVE.
IN YOUR IN THE PAROLE BUSINESS
SO.
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE INTERESTED IN IN
TRYING TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE WHO
WERE IN THAT SITUATION.
HARPER GIVEN THE TOOLS NECESSARY
TO SUCCEED TO SUCCEED IN LIFE
AND MOVE MOVE ON PAST THE
PERHAPS PAST MISTAKES.
HOW EFFECTIVE IS CDC ARE IN
PROVIDING SUPPORT SERVICES -- TO
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE ON
PAROLE IN TERMS OF ALLOWING THEM
TO REENTER SOCIETY ARE YOU IN A
POSITION. TO TO MAKE A STATEMENT
ON THAT.
I AM IN IN BECAUSE OF THE
DEDICATION FOR MANY YEARS AND I
ALSO DEALT WITH PAROLE VIOLATORS.
AND SO I SAW ALL THE SUPPORT
SERVICES THAT THEY HAD IN THE
COMMUNITY WITH REGARDS TO
CONTINUE IN PROGRAMMING.
AND THAT'S WHAT'S NEEDED THEY
HAVE A PROGRAM INSIDE THE
INSTITUTION BUT WANTS TO RELEASE
IT HAS TO CONTINUE ONE BECAUSE
THERE REALLY BILL TATIAN HAS TO
CONTINUE.
BECAUSE THIS LIKE THE EXISTING
WANTED ATTIC ALWAYS AN ADDICT WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE AWARE.
OF THEIR ISSUES AND ALSO MAKE
SURE THE PROGRAM IS STILL STILL
THERE IN YOUR LIVES.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE AS
COMMISSIONERS -- HAVE STATUTORY
AUTHORITY TO DO IS IMPOSE
SPECIAL CONDITIONS ON PAROLE SO
WHAT WE CAN DO IS SAY.
WE'RE WE'RE GOING TO RE RELEASE --
THIS PERSON WITH -- THE SPECIAL
CONDITIONS AND WE CAN IMPOSE
CONDITIONS THAT INCLUDE EXTRA
PROGRAMMING WE CAN REQUEST THAT
THEY OR WE CAN ORDER THAT THEY
GO TO A FOOT YOU KNOW POSSIBLY --
LIKE A FIFTY TWO WEEK BETTER
SCORES OR CONTINUE THEIR A ES IN
RECOVERY -- BE IN TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING FOR SIX MONTHS NINE
MONTHS A YEAR TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT TRANSITION THEY GET THAT
ASSISTANCE THAT -- PROVIDED IN
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING SO WE HAVE --
THE STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO BE IN
ORDER EXTRA -- SPECIAL CONDITION
SO THAT IT REALLY ASSIST THEM AS
THEY RE INTEGRATE INTO SOCIETY
OUR OUR SPECIAL CONDITIONS
IMPOSE VERY OFTEN.
I PROBABLY HAVE NOT HAD A
HEARING THAT I DIDN'T IMPOSE A
SPECIAL CONDITION OF PROGRAM
HERE ABSOLUTELY.
THANK YU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
RESPONSES CONGRATULATIONS I LOOK
FORWARD.
TO MOVING YOUR CONFIRMATIONS AT
THE APPROPRIATE POINT.
THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES MAKER
YOU.
WELL LET ME ADD MY
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU TO YOUR
APPOINTMENTS AND THANK YOU ARE
YOU HOLDING MY OFFICE EARLIER.
TODAY AND IT WAS A VERY VERY
INFORMATIVE DISCUSSION AND I
COMMEND YOU FOR YOUR COMMITMENT.
AND YOUR PASSION FOR DOING THIS
VERY VERY DIFFICULT JOB AND
GIVING PEOPLE HOPEFULLY ANOTHER
CHANCE IF THEY DESERVE IT AND I
KNOW YOU TAKE THAT VERY
SERIOUSLY.
WE DID HAVE A LITTLE DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE STRUCTURED DECISION
MAKING -- FRAMEWORK BECAUSE THAT
SHE REACHED RECENTLY HAVE THE
TRAINING FOR A AND THERE WAS A
MENTION TO YOU THEM THERE WERE
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS -- AND
ACTUALLY HOW IT IS -- IT IS USED
IN THE HEARING PROCESS THE LA A
WILL RAISE SOME ISSUES ABOUT.
THE FUNDING OF THAT BASED ON
THEM NOT HAVING THAT MUCH
INFORMATION YOU CERTAINLY DID IN
OUR CONVERSATION SO.
I HEARING A WITH ALSO A MOMENT
HERE I THINK I'LL BE VERY
HELPFUL FOR ME HOW IT'S APPLIED.
THE IT'S A START MOST PEOPLE
WHEN THEY THINK OF THE STRUCTURE
DECISION MAKING TOOL I THINK OF
AS ALGORITHM AS FAR AS HAVING US
DETERMINE IF GRANT WITH THE
REDEPLOYMENT GRANT THE INMATE.
OR WE'RE GOING TO KEEP HIM IN
PRISON.
IT'S NOT LIKE THE A SIMPLY AS A
TOOL TO HELP THE DEPUTY
COMMISSION COMMISSIONER
CALLEGARI. TO COME TO A
CONCLUSION AS FAR AS WATER RISK
FACTORS AND WHAT ARE THE AT THE
ISSUES THAT WE SHOULD BE FOCUSED
ON NOT SIMPLY TALKING ABOUT THE
LIFE.
STATIC BUT ACTUALLY FOCUSING ON
WHEN THE RISK TO THIS PARTICULAR
INMATE.
AND TO FOCUS THE HEARING UPON TO
FIFTY THAT AND NOT THE ACTUAL BY
CRIME ITSELF BUT FOCUSED ONE OF
INTERCHANGE THEY HAVE TO
DEFENDER ACTUALLY CHANGED.
SO WE END AND SOLD THE TOOL THAT
WE USE HAS -- NUMEROUS DOMAINS
AND IN EACH ONE OF THOSE BILLS
DOMAIN WEEK THOSE TO ME AS WE GO
THROUGH.
EACH ONE AND WE'RE REALLY
LOOKING AT RISK FOR RE OFFENSE
BASED ON RESEARCH.
AND SO WE GO THROUGH EACH DOMAIN
AND AT THE END OF THE DOMAINS
MAY SAY LIKE FOR EXAMPLE
CRIMINAL HISTORY -- THIS INMATE
MIGHT HAVE HAD AN EXTENSIVE
CRIMINAL HISTORY WITH THEIR
CRIMES BEING VERY CLOSE IN --
PROXIMITY THERE YOU KNOW ONE
RIGHT AFTER ANOTHER WE MAY SAY
THAT'S AGGRAVATED AND WE GO
THROUGH THE DOMAINS AND THEN
BASED ON THAT INFORMATION.
THEN WE WE WE KNOW OKAY AT THE
VERY BEGINNING OF HIS LIFE THIS
IS WHAT WAS GOING ON WITH HIM.
WERE WERE NOW TWENTY FIVE YEARS
LATER -- HAS THERE BEEN CHANGE
AND WE REALLY FOCUS ON THE
CHANGE WE STILL HAVE DISCRETION.
ON IT'S NOT IT'S NOT THIS CHECK
SYSTEM IMMUNE YOU KNOW NUMBERS
AND THEN THIS EQUALS THAT IT IS
FOCUSED ON THESE ARE THE HIGHEST
RISK FACTORS FOR THIS INMATE AND
HAS HE RESOLVED THEM.
AND IF HE HAS HE WE'VE BEEN MAKE
SOME DETERMINATIONS BASED ON
SOME CONVERSATION EVIDENCE IN
THE RECORD THINGS THAT WE
PREVIEWED -- ON WHETHER OR NOT
WE THINK HE IS SUITABLE FOR
PAROLE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU ARE I CERTAINLY
DON'T HAVE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
BUT AGAIN CONGRATULATIONS SANDRA.
IMPRESSIVE RESUMES THAT YOU BOTH
BRING TO US THANKS AGAIN.
YOU CENTER.
THANK YOU SENATOR MINING.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I ALSO
WANT TO ADD MY CONGRATULATIONS
TO BOTH OF YOU IN.
PERHAPS MORE IMPORTANTLY OUR
THANKS FOR YOUR SERVICE TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- THINK
AUSTER WITH MR SHARIF WE
DISCUSSED EARLIER.
LITTLE BIT THE THE CHALLENGE OF
CONDUCTING A PAROLE HEARING WHEN
THERE ARE.
VICTIMS ARE FAMILY MEMBERS OF
VICTIMS PARTICIPATING IN THE
PROCESS.
YOU SHARED WITH ME A LITTLE BIT
HOW YOU APPROACH -- CREATING A
FOUNDATION IN A CONTEXT IN IF
YOU COULD JUST SHARE THAT WITH
US HOW YOU.
DO THAT BALANCING ACT -- TO
AFFORD RESPECT TO VICTIMS AND
THEIR FAMILIES ABSOLUTELY AT THE
ONSET OF A HEARING HI ME WITH
THE VICTIMS WHAT THE VICTIMS OF
THE CAN.
AND LET THEM KNOW NUMBER ONE THE
FORMAT OF THE HEARING.
AND ALSO THERE IS A POSSIBILITY
THAT THIS COULD BE A GRANT.
IF IT IS THE GRANT THEY HAVE
THEIR FORTY OPPORTUNITY TO NOT
COME BACK INSIDE THE ROOM.
A BECAUSE I DON'T WANT THEM TO
BE UPSET AND I ACTUALLY WE LIVE
THE TRAUMA ONCE AGAIN.
ALSO THE LET THEM KNOW THE LAW.
AS FAR AS WHAT OF OUR STANDARDS
IN WHAT WE LOOKING AS FAR AS
WITHIN THE CITY MAY SHOULD BE
FOUND SUITABLE FOR PAROLE.
IF YOU'RE SHEET METAL STANDARDS
I HAVE TO FOLLOW THE LAW IN
PRACTICE PERSON WITH AN AYE THIS
PERSON IS SO I WANT TO SET THE
FRAME WHAT ARE FRAMEWORK UP.
SO THAT THE VICTIMS OR THE
VICTIMS THAT CAN UNDERSTAND
NUMBER ONE WHAT WE'RE DOING AND
WHY ARE WE DOING IT AND NOT TO
BE SORT BY SIDE SO TO SPEAK.
BUT I WANT THEM TO BE NUMBER ONE
FEEL COMFORTABLE IN A ROOM AND
IT WILL ALSO BE BE HEARD.
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT -- MISS
MINOR WE DISCUSS SOME.
MY QUESTION WENT TO DIFFERENT
PRISONS HAVING DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS AVAILABLE FROM.
MAYBE A LOT OF PROGRAMS TO MAYBE
NOT SO MANY AND I FOUND YOUR
RESPONSE TO THAT QUESTION IF IF
YOU COULD SHARE.
WHAT ROLE YOU THINK THAT PLAYS
AND HOW THAT AFFECTS WERE NOT?
WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING FOR DURING A
PAROLE HEARING?
AND SO I I'VE BEEN PROGRAMMING
IS REALLY IMPORTANT BUT
SOMETIMES PROGRAMMING IS NOT
AVAILABLE.
AND THERE ARE MEN AND WOMEN WHO
REALLY TAKE THE INITIATIVE.
TO IDENTIFY WHAT SEEMS NEEDED TO
CHANGE AND THE DO SELF STUDY
THEY GO TO THE LIBRARY THEY
REALLY -- GET INTO INFORMATION
THAT REALLY ASSIST THEM IN IN IN
THEIR CHANGING SO THEY MAY NOT
BE IN A FORMALIZED PROGRAM THEY
MAY START A PROGRAM.
ON THERE'S IN BUILDING --
PROGRAMS THAT INMATES START IN
WHICH THEY MAY NOT BE A
AVAILABLE BUT THEY KNOW THE
TWELVE STEPS AND THEY KNOW HOW
TO WORK -- SO THEY GET TOGETHER
ON THEIR OWN AND THEY START TO
TO WORK THOSE STEPS SO THAT THEY
CAN WORK ON THEIR RECOVERY AND
SO SOMETIMES WHEN PROGRAMS ARE
NOT AVAILABLE -- THEY TAKE THE
INITIATIVE -- TO FIND THINGS
THAT WILL ASSIST THEM OR EVEN
GET A OTHER DOCUMENTS FROM OR
YOU KNOW SOME OF THE LESSONS
FROM.
PROGRAMS THAT.
OF OTHER OFFENDERS ARI AND HAND
pTO THAT PROGRAM INFORMATION TO
CHECK TO WORK ON THEIR CHANGE
AND SO SOMETIMES.
WE WE WOULD REALLY LIKE.
A LOT OF THEM TO BE ABLE TO GET
INTO ADDITIONAL PROGRAMS MORE
BUT WHEN THERE ARE NO PROGRAMS
AVAILABLE.
AND MANY OF THE INMATES HAVE
FOUND WAYS -- TO REALLY WORK ON
THEIR CHANGE THANK YOU AND I
THINK YOU'D ALSO POINTED OUT
THAT.
JUST CHECKING BOXES OF HAVING
TAKEN A PROGRAM DOESN'T
NECESSARILY SATISFY WHAT YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR IN TERMS OF THIS
PERSON REALLY MANIFEST REFORM
AND CHANGE.
SO CERTAINLY WE CAN SEE WE OWE
THE INMATES COME IN AND TELL US
THEY'VE CHANGED AND THEN WE CAN
LOOK AT THE RECORD WE CAN LOOK
AT INFORMATION IN THERE SEE FILE
AND AND SEE THAT.
THAT'S NOT THE CASE THEIR
BEHAVIOR HASN'T CHANGED BECAUSE
THERE MAY BE RULE VIOLATION
REPORTS THAT TELL US THAT.
THEY MAY SAY THAT -- THEY'VE YOU
KNOW REALLY TRIED IN SCHOOL BUT
THE TEACHER MAY PROVIDE A
DOCUMENT THAT SAID THAT HE
DOESN'T PARTICIPATE IN IN HIS
EDUCATION OUR SO THERE'S THERE'S
DIFFERENT WAYS TO TO FIND OUT
WHETHER OR NOT THEY ARE
PARTICIPATING THAT THEY ARE.
CHANGING AND IF THERE ARE
CHANGES REAL -- MANY OF THE MEN
THAT ARE CHANGING DO A LOT OF
SERVICE THEY GIVE BACK TO OTHER
INMATES -- MEN THAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN IN WOMEN THAT MAY HAVE
NEVER BEEN OF SERVICE ARE NOW --
IN PRISONS AS GOAL CODES THE
MATTER THAT THAT'S IN MAKES THAT
ARE HELPING OTHER INMATES THAT
ARE ILL SOME OF MARKET HOSPICE
PROGRAM SOME OF MARK PUSHERS
WHERE THEY PUSH THE OTHER
INMATES THAT ARE IN WHEELCHAIRS
AND SO.
WHEN YOU SEE THOSE CRIME OWES
YOU SEE THAT THERE'S BEEN SOME
CHANGE -- AND THAT MAYBE THE IN
AND THAT THE CHANGE THAT YOU'RE
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT IS IS REAL.
ME WELL I WANT TO THANK YOU BOTH
FOR YOUR BOTHA.
MANIFEST A GREAT DEDICATION TO
YOUR WORK IN A THOROUGHNESS AND
I'LL BE HAPPY TO SUPPORT.
YOUR CONFIRMATION AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU SENATOR MONNING.
LET ME ASK AND I WANNA -- THANK
YOU BOTH FOR BEING HERE I THINK
IN PASSED RULES COMMITTEE
HEARINGS ON THIS I KNOW WE'VE.
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO TO SEE YOU
BEFORE.
MISS WATER -- HI THIS IS
INCREDIBLY HARD WORK -- I THINK
AND AND THAT HAS TO BE
ACKNOWLEDGED AGAIN -- IN YOUR
TIME BECAUSE YOU ACTUALLY I HAD
A CAREER AT CDC ARE AND NOW
YOU'VE BEEN DOING THIS A NUMBER
OF YEARS -- THE IN TERMS OF
ASSESSMENT OF OUR AND IN THE END
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE GOTTEN TO IN
TERMS OF THE PROGRAMS AND
READING THIS.
DO YOU SEE -- RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT SHOULD BE MADE TO CDC ARE
AS IT RELATES -- TO ANY OTHER
ISSUE -- AND I KNOW THAT'S A
DIFFICULT QUESTION TO BE PUT IN
YOUR WAY BUT IN TERMS OF THE
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS THE THE
SERVICES PROVIDED TO TRY TO GET
INMATES READY THAT MAY BE A
LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN THAT YOU
KNOW SCHOOL EDUCATION.
I'M TRYING TO FIND -- A AWAY TO
SEE IF THERE ARE IMPROVEMENTS
THAT NEED TO BE MADE WITHIN THE
SYSTEM.
AND YOU GET TO BE AT THE END OF
THE SYSTEM BUT YOU'VE BEEN IN
TERMS OF PEOPLE READY FOR
CONSIDERATION AND GRANTED PAROLE
BUT YOU'VE ALSO BEEN IN THIS IN
THE INSTITUTION.
SO.
ANYTHING YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHARE.
I THINK THAT.
REALLY SEEING.
ADDITIONAL REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE AVAILABLE TERM.
OF A BIGGER NUMBER OF INMATES
WOULD BE HELPFUL -- I THINK THE
TYPE OF PROGRAMMING -- REALLY
FOCUSING -- OR OR MAYBE EVEN
ADDITIONAL PROGRAMMING THAT
BETTER IS COGNITIVE BEHAVIORAL
THERAPY PROGRAMMING WOULD BE
HELPFUL -- MANY TIMES WE GO TO
FACILITIES AND AND THEY'RE
REALLY REGION PROGRAMS AND THEN
WE GO TO PROGRAMS AND FACILITIES
IS ARE NOT BETTER NOT SO REGION
PROGRAMS I'D LIKE TO SEE ALL THE
FACILITIES BE RICH IN PROGRAM --
SO THAT WE CAN REALLY START TO
SEE MORE OFFENDER CHANGE BECAUSE
THESE OFFENDERS ARE GONNA MANY
OF THEM ARE GOING TO BE BACK IN
OUR COMMUNITIES.
SO I HAD CAN YOU HAZARD.
A GUESS AS TO WHY SUMMER RICH IN
PROGRAMS AND OTHERS ARE NOT.
YEAH I I DON'T I DON'T HAVE THE
ANSWER TO THAT I'M NOT SURE I
MEAN YOU THINK ABOUT A PLACE
LIKE SAN QUENTIN I THANK
WOULDN'T HAS A LOT OF VOLUNTEERS.
AND SO THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE
IN THAT AREA THAT GIVE A LOT OF
TIME TO THAT PERSON AND AND
THEY'RE ENGAGED IN -- HE IN --
SOME OF THE PROGRAMS ARE -- THAT
WE HEAR A LOT ABOUT ARE PROVIDED
BY THE VOLUNTEERS -- AND SO.
I'M NOT SURE I DON'T KNOW THE
ANSWER TO WHY BUT I DO KNOW THAT --
WHEN YOU GO TO PROBE WHEN YOU GO?
TO FACILITIES THAT HAVE A LOT OF
OFFENDER PROGRAMMING.
THE HEARINGS ARE ARE QUITE
DIFFERENT THEY'RE THEY'RE
TALKING CHANGE IT EVERYBODY
SEEMS TO REALLY EMBRACE CHANGE --
AND EVEN THE OFFICERS YOU KNOW
EVEN THE OFFICERS HAVE A
DIFFERENT -- EVEN IT WAY OF
INTERACTING AND SO I THINK IF WE
COULD JUST INFUSE THIS THANK THE
SYSTEM WITH PROGRAMS THAT BE
GREAT.
SO LET ME DIRECT -- MY COMMENT
HERE TO ACTUALLY STAFF OF THE
RULES COMMITTEE AND THOSE WHO
HELP US PREPARE.
QUESTIONS -- FOR APPOINTEES WHEN
WE GET TO THE CDC OUR
APPOINTMENTS FOR ADMINISTRATOR
SECRETARIES ETCETERA THAT'S A
QUESTION WE NEED TO ASK WHY SOME
PROGRAM SEEM TO BE.
A RICHER AND IN TERMS OF VARIOUS
SERVICES AND PROGRAMS
[inaudible]
I APPRECIATE.
YOUR HELPING US OUT WITH THIS
FOR SOME OF US HAVE BEEN SITTING
HERE FOR A COUPLE YEARS NOT
ALIVE I I MEAN THE EXPERTISE IS
RIGHT OUT THERE -- AS I LOOK AT
GOVERNOR'S -- STAFF WHO HAVE
WORKED VERY HARD TO FILL THESE
APPOINTMENTS.
THEY'RE NOT EASY APPOINTMENTS TO
FILL TO FIND THE RIGHT KIND OF
PERSON WITH THE RIGHT KIND OF
DEMEANOR WITH THE RIGHT KIND OF
SKILLS.
AND SO I THINK MY COLLEAGUES AND
I CONTINUALLY TRY TO FIGURE OUT.
HOW TO IMPROVE UPON THE LARGEST
PRISON SYSTEM IN THE WORLD AND
TO GET IT RIGHT AND YOUR KEY
PIECE OF THAT IN TERMS OF WHAT
YOU PROVIDE US IN FEEDBACK?
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT THERE I MEAN
OTHER THAN I THINK SENATOR BATES
WHO HAS TRAINING IN SOCIAL WORK
AND OF COURSE OUR MEDIATOR DOWN
THERE AND I HAVE AN ATTORNEY TO
ATTORNEYS.
MAYBE I'M THE ONLY ONE WITHOUT
THE EXPERIENCE STICK TO GAUGE
THIS BUT I THINK WE'RE TRYIN TO
LOOK AT THE SYSTEM FROM EVERY
PIECE.
GIVEN THE CHALLENGES WE HAVE SO
I APPRECIATE THAT -- MR SHREVE I
WOULD ASK YOU I YOU'RE
RELATIVELY NEW BUT NOT REALLY.
WHAT IS THE MOST I'D?
I GUESS -- SURPRISING THING YOU
HAVE LEARNED AND YOUR TIME I
MEAN YOU WERE -- IT A DEPUTY
COMMISSIONER AND NOW.
THIS APPOINTMENT YOU'VE BEEN
DOING IT FOR AT LEAST A YEAR TWO
YEARS.
THE COMMISSION FOR ABOUT A YEAR
A FEW MONTHS AND A COMMISSIONER
FOR SIX MONTHS OKAY SO COUPLE
YEARS.
ANOTHER TO ENOUGH TO GAUGE WHAT
YOU'RE MOST SURPRISED AT IN
TERMS OF WHAT YOU HAVE TO DEAL
WITH VERSUS WHAT YOU THOUGHT.
IN JUST A FOLLOW UP ALSO ARE
WITHIN ME COUNSEL FOR CLOSE TO
FIFTEEN YEARS AS WELL.
AND SO I KINDA UNDERSTAND FROM
ALL SIDES OF THE OF THE TABLE --
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT SURPRISED
ME WAS THE THE SCHEDULE GRUELING
SCHEDULE.
AND BEING [inaudible]
YOU'RE CONSTANTLY.
AT WORK SEVEN DAYS A WEEK.
AND THE IF YOU DO NOT WANT THIS
CHILD IS AT THE JOB FOR YOU BUT
IF YOU ENJOY HELPING OTHERS AND
BEING OF SERVICE.
THIS IS THIS IS THE RIGHT JOB
FOR YOU AND I'M A GLUTTON FOR
PUNISHMENT.
YEAH THAT DOES IS I JUST HAVE TO
SAY THAT IF I GOT EVERYTHING I
DO I CHALLENGE MYSELF IN HIS JOB
IS A HUGE CHALLENGE.
BY.
BECAUSE TIMES ETCETERA MONEY
IT'S NOT ABOUT ME.
THIS JOB IS NOT ABOUT ME.
THE SHOP ABOUT HELPING OTHERS IN
SO ALTHOUGH THIS IS A VERY
GRUELING JOB THE VERY REWARDING
JOB AS WELL.
WHAT I'M GONNA COME HOME ON
FRIDAY EVENINGS I'M EXHAUSTED
FROM STILL SATISFIED VOTE
SATISFIED IN ENOUGH JUST TO GET
ME GOING AGAIN FOR THE FOLLOWING
WEEK?
BECAUSE WE ARE HELPING OTHERS WE
HELPING OTHERS IN SO THAT'S WHY
I ENJOY THIS JOB.
AND I I APPRECIATE I BECAUSE
CLEARLY YOU YOU MUST ENJOY THE
JOB IT ISN'T JUST THE PAY
BECAUSE I'M NOT SURE YOU GET I
DON'T EVEN WANT TO KNOW WHAT
YOUR MINIMUM WAGES -- GIVEN WHAT
YOU JUST SAID TO ME -- I IS SO I
APPRECIATE THE COMMITMENT AND
THE PASSION IN TERMS OF TRAINING
I ASKED THIS LAST TIME -- WE
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
WAS -- ADEQUATE TRAINING
PROVIDED AS A RELATED TO THE
DIVERSITY OF THE INMATESI
INCLUDING TRANS GENDER.
A GENDER NON CONFORMING --
OTHERS DO YOU HAVE A DID YOU GET --
TRAINING -- WE A LOT OF TRAINING
WE HAVE TRAIN AS IT BECAME
MISSION AND COMMISSIONER.
I SPOKE WITH STAFF ATTORNEY FOR
AT LEAST THREE HOURS JEFF ON
TRANSGENDER ISSUES ALL ALONE.
AND WE ALSO HAD DIFFERENT TWENTY
A FEW MONTHS AGO AND CHANGES IN
ANY ISSUES AS WELL AND SO WE
HAVE A LOT OF TRAINING AREA A
LOT.
AND AN IMPLICIT BIAS IS INCLUDED
ABSOLUTELY OKAY ABSOLUTELY IN
TERMS OF THE TRAINING YOU GET
REGULARLY.
AND DO YOU HAVE I DON'T KNOW
GIVEN IT HAVE YOU HAD
EXPERINCES WITH TRANS GENDER
GENDER NON CONFORMING.
THE LEAD AS A PRIVATE ATTORNEY I
REPRESENTED -- A YOUNG WOMAN WHO
WAS ACCUSED OF MURDER.
AND UP ON ANOTHER TRANSGENDER
WOMAN.
AND THAT WAS MY FIRST ACTUAL
EXPERIENCE OF THE O. TRAIN
GINGER -- COMMUNITY AND SO I
HAVE TO BE EDUCATED BY MY CLIENT.
ABOUT THE CHANGE IN OUR
COMMUNITY BECAUSE I WAS SO FAR
REMOVED AND SO I WAS
ADDITIONALLY -- TRAINED WHEN I
CAME TO THE BOARD BECAUSE THEY
WERE O MUCH I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
NON BINARY THERE'S SO MANY
ISSUES I HAD NO IDEA HOW.
FIT SO WE HAD A LOT OF EXTRA
TRAINING.
MR SURE IF I'M A MEMBER OF THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY AND TRUST ME YOU
ARE NOT ALONE -- WE'RE LEARNING
EVERY DAY AND I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT IT YOU KNOW OUR OUR PRISON
SYSTEM IS OVERWHELMED WITH NEEDS
AND ISSUES THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED FACILITIES NEED OUR
RESOURCES -- THE PROGRAMS AND I
IS IT IS HARD TO KEEP UP WITH
THE CHANGING WORLD.
AND SO -- WE HAVE HEARD CONCERNS
FROM THE COMMUNITY AND PEOPLE%
WHO HAVE COME OUT OF PRISON.
IN TERMS OF THE ISSUES AND NEEDS
WITHIN AND DOT YOU WILL SEE
PIECES OF LEGISLATION COME
FORWARD THEY TRY TO ADDRESS
ISSUES AROUND HOUSING AND SAFETY
AND ALL KINDS OF THINGS BUT I
DON'T KNOW THAT WERE I THINK
WE'VE GOT SOME WORK TO DO THERE
SO -- ANYTHING YOU WANT TO ADD
IN TERMS OF ANY CASE IT HAVE YOU
HEARD FROM ANY EITHER VIEW
ACTION IS MINOR BECAUSE YOU'VE
BEEN THERE QUITE AWHILE -- OF
GENDER NON CONFORMING OR OR
POPULATION OR COMMUNITY THAT
FEELS LIKE THEY'VE BEEN TARGETED
FOR ANY REASON WITHIN THE SYSTEM.
HAS ANY OF THAT KIND OF MADE ITS
WAY.
INTO THE INTO THE CASES THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING AT IS YOUR
CONSIDERING.
THIS IS A THE LAST FOLLOW UP I
DID HAVE A A CASE WHERE.
THE INMATE WITH THE TRANSITION --
ONE IN.
AND I HAVE TO REMIND IN MAY
COUNCIL. TO CONSERVE OUR PROPER
PRONOUN.
BECAUSE THE VALUE ME COUNSEL
KEPT SAYING HE HE AT THE OFFICE
OF THE HEARING I MADE SURE.
I HAS HOW DO YOU WANT TO BE
REFERRED.
TO AND WHAT WHAT NAME BECAUSE
SHE ACTUALLY CHANGE YOUR NAME AS
WELL AND SO I KNOWLEDGE OR CDC
NAME BUT THEY'RE ON A RECORD I
ONLY CALLED HER.
BY NAME DOES SHE WANT TO BE
CALLED BUT I HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT REMINDED EVERYONE IN A ROOM.
USE THE PROPER PROGRAMS.
NOW HOPEFULLY THOSE REGULATIONS
ARE AT IT RELATED TO THE BILL I
DID ON NAME CHANGE WILL.
BE FORTH COMING BUT I APPRECIATE
THE TIME YOUR HELP ME TO HAVE A
LOOK INSIDE AND UNDERSTAND.
WHAT YOU'RE DEALING WITH I AGREE
WITH MY COLLEAGUES I APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME AND YOUR?
YOUR COMMENTS I'M GOING TO ASK --
DID YOU WANT TO RESPOND ON THAT
MISS BONNER I'M SORRY I DIDN'T.
SO I I HAVE CONDUCTED -- COUPLED
HEARINGS ON TRANSGENDER FEMALES
AND WHAT I WHAT I HAVE -- BUT A
IT IN ONE PARTICULAR CASE WHEN I
RAN INTO WAS REALLY HAVING.
TO TAKE A REALLY GOOD LOOK AT
THE RULE VIOLATION REPORTS --
THAT ALONG THE PRISON IN THE
DATE THE TIME IN WHICH THE
INMATE WAS IN PRISON -- AND
REALLY WHAT I FOUND WAS THAT THE
THERE WAS A A POINT IN TIME
WHERE THERE MAY HAVE BEEN MORE
VICTIMIZATION THAN.
VIOLENCE -- ON THE BEHALF OF THE
INMATE AND SO I HAD TO REALLY
TAKE A GOOD LOOK AT WHY DID THIS
HAPPEN IN WAS.
THIS PERSON WAS HE BEING PICKED
WHICH SHE BEING VICTIMIZED AND
AND WE DETERMINE JUST BASED ON
READING THE RULE VIOLATION
REPORTS THAT.
IT WAS NOT THAT THIS PERSON WAS
A VIOLENT.
PERSON IT WAS THAT THE PERSON
WAS BEING VICTIMIZED IN THE WAY
THAT INFORMATION WAS BEING
PROVIDED KIND OF DIDN'T.
DIDN'T TELL THE WHOLE STORY
UNTIL WE DID A DEEPER DIVE AND
SO I I DO KNOW THAT WE TAKE A IN
PARTICULAR TAKE.
A BIT OF CARE WHEN WE'RE LOOKING
AT BEHAVIOR AND WHAT HAPPENED IN
WHICH IS NOT LOOKING AT ALL THIS
IS A RULE VIOLATION THEREFORE
YOU ARE DANGEROUS FOR LOOKING AT
WHAT WAS REALLY GOING ON WERE
YOU BEING VICTIMIZED IN WAS THIS
RIGHT AT THE TIME OF YOUR
TRANSITION.
YOUR TRANSITION AND CHANGE --
AND AND WE REALLY ARE MINDFUL OF
OF TAKING THAT EXTRA TIME TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES AND THEN NOT.
NOT THAT BE NOT AN AGGRAVATING
FACTOR -- BECAUSE A LOT OF TIMES
WE A REVITALIZATION FOR VIOLENCE
EQUALS YOU KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO
BE BY THE COMMUNITY BUT THAT.
IS NOT ALWAYS THE CASE WELL THAT
WAS HELPFUL THANK YOU -- OKAY
LET ME SEE IF THERE ARE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN SUPPORT.
COM MEMBERS IN OPPOSITION OF THE
PUBLIC WHO ARE HERE.
OKAY.
THAT'S GOOD OUR MISTER SENATOR
ROTH.
OKAY THANK YOU AND WE ARE GOING
TO SPLIT THE ABSOLUTELY -- WE'RE
GONNA GO BACK TO MY AGENDA WE
ARE GOING TO SPLIT A AND B. AND
SENATE RACE WHICH ONE DID YOU
WANT TO COMMENT ON GARY.
I ON IS IT BE YES MR SHARIF OKAY
YES OKAY -- WHY DON'T WE GO
AHEAD I'LL TAKE A MOTION ON ITEM
A?
AND MADAM SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL.
SENATORS BATES.
AYE BATES AYE MONNING.
MONNING AYE ROSS ROSS AYE WILK
ATKINS HI ATKINS AYE THANK YOU
THAT IS FOUR ZERO WITHIN ABSENCE
CONGRATULATIONS.
SENATOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO
ON ITEM NUMBER V. -- MA'AM
SECRETARY.
SENATORS BATES -- COMMENT IF I
MIGHT YEAH I MEAN I AM GOING TO
ABSTAIN TODAY I INTEND TO
SUPPORT.
MR SHOULD READ FILE WHEN I'M ON
THE FLOOR WELL WE HAD A FEW
QUESTIONS ON OUR MEMBERS DID NOT
HAVE ENOUGH TIME TO REALLY.
GET THAT HOT AFTER MY MEETING
WITH HIM IN MY OFFICE AND HIS
COMMENTS TODAY I AM ABOUT TO
LEAVE VERY SUPPORTIVE BUT I
THINK I HAVE TO RESPECT ON MY
COLD MEMBERS NOT HERE TODAY.
AND THERE WERE A FEW OF THE OF
THE ACT ON ON WITNESS GROUPS
THAT WANTED TO HAVE A LITTLE
MORE INFORMATION SO I WILL BE
ADVOCATING FOR YOU I GUESS.
WHEN WE GET THERE BUT TODAY I
WILL HAVE SEEN?
SENATOR THANK YOU FOR THAT --
SENATORS MONNING.
MONNING AYE ROTH.
ROTH AYE WILK ATKINS AYE ATKINS
AYE.
THAT IS GOOD CONGRATULATIONS.
THREE ZERO THREE ONE ZERO AND WE
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND YOUR COMMITMENT TO THIS AND
THANK YOU FOR GIVING US A LITTLE
BIT MORE INSIDE.
WE DO APPRECIATE IT AND THE JOB
THAT YOU DO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE FOR
THIS -- WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK --
TO THE CONSENT AGENDA THAT WOULD
BE GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES ITEM TO
NOT REQUIRED TO APPEAR.
MISS -- DOCTOR YEP -- ITEM
NUMBER THREE BILL REFERRALS ITEM
FOR RULE THERE IS A RURAL WAIVER
REQUESTS FROM SENATOR MITCHELL.
AND THEN FLOORING KNOWLEDGE
MINTS ON ITEMS FIVE AND SIX THAT
IS THE CONSENT AGENDA IF SOMEONE
WOULD LIKE TO MOVE IT.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES MADAM
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS BATES.
BATES I'D MONNING.
MONNING AYE ROSS ROSS I A WILK
ATKINS HI CAN SCIENCE AN AGENDA
PASSES FOUR ZERO WITH MR WILK
ABSENT.
AND THAT IS THE THE THE EXTENT
OF OUR BUSINESS TODAY SO OUR
MEETING IS ADJOURNED